una economía golpeada en una época de
campaña por esos días para muchos
estadounidenses el aumento del costo de
vida es el tema principal para estas
elecciones en septiembre la inflación
interanual alcanzó un
8.2%. la más alta desde 1982 crisis una
madre de tres hijos pide ayuda
ni siquiera puedo llevarlos para tomar
un helado solo algo tan pequeño como eso
y siento que nunca voy a recuperar este
tiempo nunca recuperaré este tiempo con
ellos
la inflación Es evidente en los
alimentos los servicios básicos y en los
precios de la vivienda y a dos semanas
de las elecciones de medio término las
cuales definirán si los demócratas
continuarán manteniendo la mayoría en el
congreso o si los republicanos
repuntarán se espera que les pase
factura por lo que este miércoles el
presidente Joe biden anunció que tomará
medidas contra las llamadas tarifas
basura refiriéndose a los sobregiros
ocultos y por Mora entre otros de bancos
y entidades privadas que según su
administración le ahorraría a sus
ciudadanos 3000 millones de dólares
anuales
hoy mi administración está anunciando
nuevas acciones para reducir el costo de
la vida cotidiana de las familias
estadounidenses para poner más dinero en
los bolsillos de los ciudadanos de clase
trabajadora y de ingresos medios para
responsabilizar a las grandes
corporaciones Y estos pasos comenzarán
inmediatamente a salvar a las personas
colectivamente
esta misma semana un tribunal Federal
bloqueo temporalmente el plan de alivios
a estudiantes anunciado en agosto una de
las promesas de campaña de baile que
pretendía condenar los pagos de
préstamos universitarios federales en
enero de 2023 y beneficiaría a más de
700 mil personas